les algues pour les baigneurs l'été au
bord de l'océan
c'est peu inspirant mais pour une
famille acadienne de la nouvelle-écosse
il n'y avait aucun doute sur le
potentiel de ces plantes aquatiques
chez les deux vo on utilisait le goémon
les algues dans le potager du jardin
pour aider à la pousse des cultures en
louis ii vous a donc fondé les algues
acadienne une entreprise louis à la
transformation d'algues je m'en rends au
dans la cuisine et ma mère me dit avant
qu'ils descendent en bas je veux juste
avertir que te plus de chambres à
coucher ici ton père à partie une
entreprise et puis il a fait un bureau
là bas ça veut dire qu'il faut que tu
trouves une autre place à dormir ce soir
des quatre employés à ses débuts
l'entreprise emploie maintenant près de
400 personnes dans une douzaine de pays
dans une de ses usines accord nous
enlever 100 nouvelle écosse matthew
fredricks s'assure de la qualité du
produit
ici on transforme ces algues en bio
stimulant pour l'agriculture sous forme
liquide ou solide
une façon de faciliter la croissance
originaire de la région
matthew friedrich n'avait jamais pensé
que ces algues que l'on retrouve en
abondance dans les zones côtières
pouvait être transformée et vendue à
grande échelle ces plantes sont
extrêmement résiliente même dans un
environnement hostile
elle pousse dans des eaux froides
survivent au mouvement des marées et
s'adapte par temps chaud en californie
un ils ont beaucoup de problèmes avec et
on procède au pour faire la croissance
des plaques nos produits et enlever la
cité reste la presse que les plantes
encan qui ont procédé aux poussées on
voit maintenant à que le climat est
beaucoup plus agressif il faut beaucoup
plus fort beaucoup plus chaud boucek
beaucoup plus de tripes et puis nos
produits et des problèmes là
l'entreprise familiale ne se concentre
pas seulement sur les plantes la
recherche et le développement prennent
une place importante dans le modèle
d'affaires afin de trouver de nouvelles
applications la matière première
elle s'est aussi diversifiée dans les
ingrédients alimentaires pour les
animaux et produits des algues
comestibles pour les humains des
aliments très populaire au japon 95 % de
notre chiffre d'affaires c'est
l'exploitation
c'est seulement après 5 % de nos
produits qui sont vendus au canada en
l'entreprise a acheté une usine en
irlande et plus récemment en écosse pour
accroître son accès à la ressource
elle veut aussi développer les marchés
en inde et en chine la famille de vous a
réussi à vendre dans le monde entier un
produit usées l'époque dans son jardin
et sinaï la veine de lits radio canada
acadie nouvelle écosse